they finally did it on Sunday FaZe
Clan's CS go roster emerged Victorious
from ESL Pro League season 17 and in so
doing it became the fourth and final
recipient of Intel's Million Dollar
Grand Slam twists became csgo's one and
only two-time and cemented himself as
one of the greats but with CS2 on the
horizon and the entryway to Global
offensives Hall of Fame about to be
sealed off forever
people are sort of wondering where does
this put twists in the conversation for
well the goat
[Music]
alright so before we start fanboying
profusely about twists let's talk merch
we have it you can too head over to
shop.thescore.com check out the Esports
collection and NAB yourself a t-shirt
hoodie or crew in any of our cool
designs and colorways okay
face unlike their NASDAQ listing phases
stock in CS go has reached an all-time
high there's no way I was making it
through this video without making one
joke about their closing mid price
phasing all the way down so yeah
the Cs go roster by winning EPL season
17 The Sensational International Super
team that is Kerrigan Rayne robs twists
and broke ticked off the last of four
tier one tournament wins they needed to
secure themselves Intel's Grand Slam and
the million dollar purse that comes with
it for those who don't know the Grand
Slam is a circuit prize that grants a
million dollars to the first roster to
win four tier one ESL operated events
inside a 10 event span prior to phase
only three rosters had ever completed
this run astralis liquid and Navi last
February phase one katowice in March
they took EPL season 15 and in July
nabbed themselves a cologne since then
All Phase needed was one more to seal
the deal
and my god did they struggle to get it
they earned middling results at EPL 16
disastrous ones at the Rio major and
lost to a hungry ferocious liquid in
katowice Nitro please clear this please
clear this
yes yes
and they see us back on top Grand Slam
here we come crazy how we go from that
to being too old by Rare Adam
real funny liquid fan no what are you
not clearing the right when the smoke
all right I hate it here I hate it here
anyway going into EPL 17 it was
resoundingly clear to everyone that this
was probably faze's best shot thanks to
some truly otherworldly USP play by robs
no like if you haven't seen this Inferno
clutch you like just
just watch
and that one should be cooked should be
oh my God Ross has got one HP but he
yeah I'm still it's a killer pit a
little bit concerned rocks
starts to hunt he has got zero margin
for error
but there's no time for this there's no
Health there's no hope oh come on don't
you dare
look at the cat there's a camera
did I mention he later did it again
against full buys yeah and it does get
there
insane somebody needs to fly this kid
back out to face it and check him PC one
more time just to just to be sure by the
time they've made their way to the Grand
finals it had become apparent to phase
specifically that this was not an
opportunity to waste FaZe knew that they
would not get another shot as good as
this one twists specifically had a
chance to make history and in his own
words wasn't gonna let it go you are
about to make history you just took one
step away not just from winning a grand
slam you're like one step away from
winning a grandson twice is that
something maybe it's like sitting
somewhere like back in your head
I put it in the front of my head Reno is
my main hunger and motivation I have the
chance to make history in this game and
then I'm not gonna let it go and he
didn't Shiro deals with Carrigan axol
traded twists with a double
he's looking for his second Intel Grand
Slap
he's trying to be the Difference Maker
to find 15 to find match point with so
much on the line twist has answered the
call battled back into the three on
three
and now he sits waiting for Rob's
contact sure robs falls out of the round
but twist is still a threat out behind
the big box another on the tally twist
is on a mission
four out of five one more to find and
these 1v1s have been where phase Thrive
baits the shot
thank you
the man who could make history tonight
thanks to the magician's absolutely
soul-destroying clutch FaZe found
themselves on Match Point against a bad
buy and the rest is literally history
they can't find a thing
they pick up the trophy and it just all
starts to break down they realize
they've done it with the upcoming Paris
major being the last ever in CS go phase
are definitively the final roster ever
to win a slam in Global Offensive it
added a ton of pressure I imagine and
ogs like Kerrigan and rain can rest easy
knowing that their legacies are both
complete and immutable but more
importantly our boy our lad twists the
Canadian sensation
did the damn thing I changed my mindset
to put the grandson before everything
and uh it's a very relieving feeling to
know that my hard work and my team's
hard work is paid off
I spend countless hours playing this
game day in and day out I don't get to
see my family the people know closest to
me know how much work I put into the
game and uh yeah it's very relieving to
know it pays off this way so where's
that leave him in terms of greatness
well like I said with CS2 on the horizon
it's a conversation people are having
where does this put
twists in like the the uh there's a
conversation I know what you mean I know
what you mean the the Hall of Fame
conversation right like hierarchy right
like where because you're right he is
nobody has what he has no he's the he's
two time right the two two times
the only na player to do all those
things yeah the short answer is it's not
my place to say is twists the N A goats
unquestionably but he has been for some
time the real question that everyone's
sort of flirting with right now
playfully or otherwise is does twists
have a claim to be called the actual
ghost it's interesting to think about
while it's true that there is no other
competitor in CS go who's amassed a
major and two slams it's hard to know
how that extra slam fares against
devices three additional Majors or the
sheer impossibility and indeed in the
midability of simple as a player I think
everyone would agree that simple remain
means the greatest individual Talent
Global Offensive has ever known Twist's
trophy case may be stacked and the fact
that he's amassed two slams worth of
silverware on two separate rosters is
remarkable but simple it's still simple
that said I agree that when you're
talking about the mikos cold zeras even
zyus of the world twists may actually
have the upper hand is twists the single
greatest CS go player of all time I
don't think so and I don't think anyone
is seriously suggesting that he is but
he has definitely inserted himself into
the conversation our boy is in no
uncertain terms one of the greats from
his genuinely inhuman mechanics to the
accolades he's amassed twist has won
everything there is to win
twice he's also 23 and has a long career
ahead of him I can't wait to see what
CS2 has in store
called zero number one I never I never
said otherwise there's no proof that I
said otherwise there's just this like
running meme that like if you just like
don't ever like don't ever even
playfully insinuate that cold Sarah is
not the greatest CS go player of all
time because Brazil will come
for you they will absolutely come for
it's almost football like it's almost
soccer tier in like how fanatical the
the fandom is like it's it's like crazy
yeah